ah mais bon sur le grand rex quand ça
m'a fait du pouy way fait ses preuves
c'est juste pour établir que moi je vais
pas faire des choses sérieuses du tout
d'accord c'était juste pour être sûr que
vous étiez encore là parce qu'il va
falloir participer parce que moi je
viens pas à dire 'je y aura pas de slide
je vais pas vous dire tout a commencé au
burundi maintenant je viens juste
vraiment faire des blagues se faire des
blagues sans prétention aucune
donc pour les gens qui ne me connaissent
pas moins de nouvelles marinas rollmann
je suis humoriste plutôt assez inconnu
du coup ça arrange et les gens qui
organisait le tête de me prendre pour
des questions de thème mais également de
budget j'ai assisté à toute la
conférence évidemment j'ai pris des
notes on a eu que des orateurs
extraordinaire ce soir j'ai pas des
commentaires à faire sur tous mais j'en
ai noté de troie qui m'ont intéressé la
première c'était sandrine codis qui est
venu nous parler de l'expansion de
l'univers c'est extraordinaire non c'est
fou moi je trouve c'est un truc de
dingue
elles maîtrisent pas mal son sujet en
plus j'ai l'impression elle enfin moi si
tu veux moi je m'intéresse aux trucs
donc j'ai vu qu'elle a loupé deux trois
détails mais pour les gens qui survole
non mais c'est vrai qu'elle a oublié de
poser des questions importantes comme
étant par exemple expansion de l'univers
certes mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour le prix à l'avenir du mètre carré
dans le 9e arrondissement par exemple
parce que tu vois tu es là tu achètes un
deux pièces étaient bien dans deux cent
mille ans proportionnellement reste de
l'univers c'est un studio tu une amortie
pas et ça l' agence spatiale européenne
n'y fait rien on ne travaille pas du
tout sûre et des compensations mais non
et c'est bien cette histoire d'expansion
de l'univers moi ça m'arrange et un
terme de parking en revanche je pense
pas du tout être pratique pour thunder
parce que tu vois si le rayon
d'application ne fait qu'augmenter on va
se retrouver dès samedi soir à faire une
année lumière de noctilien pour arriver
chez un mec gentil mais qui habite chez
ses parents face à maître chien
globalement je pense donc je pense qu'il
faudrait que tous ensemble on disait
l'univers y arrête de theix penser en
fait
arrête tous les garçons dans la salle
sont d'accord pour dire c'est pas la
taille qui compte voilà des messieurs
qui ont des petits univers sale ça
s'entend non mais c'est vrai c'est pas
la taille qui on est très satisfait avec
l'univers comme il est aujourd'hui non
c'est alors qu'en plus c'est une
question de température et section danse
du rebond voilà 93 milliards d'années
lumière c'est dans la norme
ça va c'est ok donc sandrine codis était
bien qui est ce qu'on a eu jean philippe
renard qui nous a parlé du darkness est
alors c'est vrai que moi ça a fait
tomber un mythe chez moi parce que
j'étais persuadé qu effectivement les
dark knight c'était un truc horrible où
tu allais pour acheter des foetus
humains et des inédits de mireille
mathieu est en fait pas du tout en fait
pas du tout darknet c'est un espace de
liberté qu'il faut protéger chose ça
bien non mais il a raison nous le dire
parce que en plus moi je trouve que dans
l'otan sont fait beaucoup de pub on est
normal alors que c'est pas vraiment un
espace très chouette le net normal il ya
déjà des trucs très très glauque qui se
passe sur le net
normal genre yale ou tripadvisor ou
google tous les gens qui ont déjà vu ce
genre de critiques savent que là c'est
vraiment la lie de l'humanité qui
s'exprime non mais on est en train de se
demander si on n'est pas trop moi je
pense il faut purger faut aller là bas
les gens qui font 16 paragraphe sur le
quick de montluçon puis le sait qu'ils
vont pas inventé le vaccin contre
l'herpès quoi tu sais sur aller non mais
tu de ces quelques pas des prix nobel
qui laisse mes commentaires kofi annan
malala youssef dahha ils sont pas là oui
alors le pire et vacances on était un
peu déçu et les acras de morue et essec
pas du tout pas du tout ça c'est des
petits soucis évidemment les deux
speakers que moi j'ai retenu quand ils
étaient tous extraordinaires mais ceux
qui m'ont un peu ému évidemment c'était
julia montfort et ludovic duguépéroux
donc elle qui a accueilli un réfugié
chez elle et lui qui va faire du
sauvetage en mer et là j'ai pas de vanne
sur eux je pense ont rajusté applaudir
en fait juste voilà
le bal mans ouais ouais c'est à dire que
moi je fais de la scène donc légaux
c'est quand même un truc assez important
chez moi j'étais pas très bien en les
regardant
je me sentais un peu petit jeu tu te
sens pas bien j'avais ce sentiment quand
je les regardais des gens qui ont des
destins tellement extraordinaires qui
sont tellement des bonnes personnes
j'avais ce sentiment si 50 quand tu
étais petit d'inviter un copain ou une
copine à la maison et tu sentais ta mère
elle les met un peu trop
c'est un moment donné à table tu saisis
16 regardant les yeux de sa mère qui
disait mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait faux
avec la nôtre tu joue du violon et aime
les épinards clara bah bravo tu as
entendu
toi tu es là tu dis non mais je vais
aller d'armes aidé le formulaire sur la
dass là ce que tu lui as pas encore dit
que tu par les mandarins clara vas-y je
me sentais un peu mal mais ce n'est pas
une excuse buzz qu'il ya des gens qui
ont des destins extraordinaires et qui
font beaucoup de bien que pour autant
nous il faut garder les mains dans les
poches
je pense que on peut tous faire à notre
échelle du bien la preuve là on est à
paris ce soir et des trucs à faire à
paris vers en termes de vivre ensemble
voyez une petite marge de progression je
vais pas dire que c'est une ville qui
est peuplé de connard mais je vais pas
dire le contraire non plus c'est quand
même mais je pense
vous vous auto flageller oui fais moi
mal je pense que c'est pas la faute des
parisiens je pense que c'est juste une
question de densité de population paris
c'est une des villes les plus denses du
monde et je pense que c'est pour ça je
pense que les incivilités c'est comme
les virus ça aime bien la densité je
pense que tous les matins à paris 99,9
pour cent des gens ils se réveillent ils
ont pas envie d'aller détruire d
existence mais le problème c'est que si
tu es de mauvaise humeur à paris dès que
tu sors tu rencontres des gens tuent les
contamines tu vois moi je vois le
contraire je suis je viens de suisse en
suisse si tu te réveilles tu es méga de
mauvaises a envie de briser des vies tu
sors y a personne tu braille un coup il
ya une boulette qui étaient rangés toi
vas tu continues tu avis on rentre pas
dans un cycle d'abus alors qu'à paris si
tu sors de chez toi tu es de mauvaise
paf tu tombe sur quelqu'un d'un métro
qui lui-même devient de mauvaises après
bouscule quelqu'un dans l'escalator qui
lui-même devient méchant ça fait déjà
trois méchants qui lui-même va la
boulangerie par le mal à la boulangère
elle devient méchante elle elle voit
défiler des gens toute la matinée elle
les rend tous méchants ça fait qu'on a
beau se réveiller tous très sympathiques
chez nous à 7 heures du matin à paris à
10h il ya la moitié de la ville qui a
envie de casser des malléoles au hasard
on sait même pas pourquoi on sait même
pas pourquoi
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
d'être gentil particulièrement avec les
inconnus parce qu'en vrai les gens dans
ton entourage
tu peux te rattraper dépassant pas avec
ta femme le matin tu reviens soir un
bouquet de fleurs un cunnilingus peu
importe mais tu vas on peut se
rabibocher tandis que les inconnus tac
une chance de faire une bonne impression
tu vois ta qu'une manière de leur dire
non on continue à croire en l'existence
il faut en profiter vous rendez pas
compte mais moi je le sais il ya des
gens dans la salle ils ont fait un doigt
un carrefour ya cinq ans depuis le gala
du psoriasis sept votes foot on plante
des graines comme ça on peut pas faire
le service après vente faut être gentil
avec les inconnus
moi je me rends compte dans ma vie de
tous les jours il ya de plus en plus
d'inconnues
parce que je vieillis et plus mon monde
c'est en plus effectivement quelqu'un
l'a dit un peu plus tôt je me rends
compte qu'il ya plein de choses que je
sais pas alors aussi à un âge un peu
bizarre j'ai eu 30 ans cette année
donc je suis ni vieilles ni jeunes moi
je suis est vieille et jeunes en même
temps c'est à dire d'un côté le
changement de couleur des feuilles sur
les arbres ça peut vraiment m'émouvoir
aux larmes de l'autre toujours pas
complètement clair sur ce que c'est la
tva
j'ai un peu mais pas vraiment et le
problème c'est que maintenant que j'ai
30 ans le grote mes interactions c'est
sur des sujets comme ça je me vois j'ai
des expériences j'ai un besoin de sortir
de mon corps et de me voir à des dîners
où j'ai des potes façon les taux
d'intérêt des fusions acquisitions de la
dette grecque par rapport à l'otan et
moi j'ai envie de leur dire je ne vois
qu'il ya des sons qui sortent la bouche
mais ça n'a aucun sens mais aucun sens
il ya plein de choses que je sais pas
dans le monde le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est trop tard pour
demander si j'aimerais demander aux gens
genre mais en vrai les impôts comment
mais je peux pas parce que je suis trop
vieille j'ai passé le cap j'ose plus le
dire c'est un problème je vis dans un
monde complètement fou lantin connu et
je laissais passer trop de temps c'est
comme quand tu sais quand tu tues tu
connais pas le prénom de quelqu'un mais
dont tu devrais connaître le prénom ça
fait genre cinq ans au moins une fois
par mois vous voyez dans le même bar tu
sais toujours pas si c'est chantal ou
jérémy ses commandes de toute ta vie il
s'appelle et
le seul moyen de feinter pour découvrir
le prénom de ces gens c'est s'il ya une
deuxième personne qui arrive tel arrêt à
charlotte
vahid va bien mais je voulais vous
présenter parce que oui et évidemment qu
est-ce qui vit à chanter mais en foot on
est champion je vais tomber mais je me
suis rendu compte
c'est ça en fait c'est comme ça qu'on
bien con qu'on arrive à un certain âge
on est d'accord d'être entouré d'un
connu mais on n'ose plus poser des
questions et on se sent obligé d'avoir
un avis de 30 ans maintenant il faut que
je dise des trucs péremptoire je vois là
et c'est ce que j'ai retenu de ce soir
si je me suis dit ok d'accord pour être
une bonne personne tous ensemble il faut
aller curieux bienveillant ouvert vers
l'inconnu il faut aussi pas oublier
quand on vous présente quelqu'un de dire
votre prénom
parce que finalement on est un peu tous
l'inconnue de quelqu'un merci beaucoup
25 personnes
[Applaudissements]